and new details tonight in the arrest of
an accused serial arsonist metro police
say 52 two-year-old juan lopez arrested
on six counts of arson with a majority
of them being car fires orco mana has
been following this story all week and
he shares how neighbors are trying to
move forward
we feel a lot better a lot safer a quiet
community breathing a sigh of relief
metro police arrested 52-year-old juan
lopez thursday on arson charges he's
accused of setting multiple cars on fire
in a neighborhood near warm springs and
eastern
8 news now was the first to show you
footage of the flames given to us by
viewers police say lopez was taken into
custody one day after our original story
aired neighbors trying to get things
back to normal us and all the neighbors
were parking on the street so that if
our cars did get lit on fire our houses
wouldn't get burned
but now obviously we're parked in the in
the driveway now according to an arrest
report obtained by 8 news now lopez was
upset his partner euthanized their sick
dog the pair had been arguing about it
for days police say security footage
from neighbors shows lopez driving away
from two car fires at the woman's home
and lighter fluid was found in his car
cleanup is underway in front of this
home where lopez is accused of setting
three more cars and even part of the
house on fire this property manager
across the street glad his tenants will
be safe it's pretty crazy
to see something like that but i'm glad
they got the guy a feeling shared by all
thank goodness they caught him orco mana
live local now